- This makeup!
- Sorry, my titties are
sweating, I'm so mad.
(blues music)
- I am actually a really
big fan of Nina Simone.
- She went through hell and back
for being a darker skinned black woman.
- She really channeled
all that into her music.
- And just her word, just
listening to her words
outside of the music itself is poetry.
- I'm super concerned.
- I don't know that she
has the spirit to do this.
- I haven't watched the
trailer for that same reason,
(chuckles) 'cause I knew
I was gonna be upset
as soon as I saw it.
- Although I love Zoe and I do love Nina,
I am not too keen on this matchup.
- Alright, I'm gonna be optimistic.
Let's just, let's see what happens.
- Okay, she's singing.
- Is she really singing?
I didn't know she could sing.
- So, basically, this is
her after she's, like,
fallen from glory.
- I like that her hair textures
look natural and all of that.
- This makeup!
- I think what's also
really hard about this
is the juxtaposition of the
black guy that they have
that's the lead because you
can just see the richness
and the realness of his tone
and, in comparison to her,
she just looks so fake.
- I feel like if David kissed
her or something, like,
her whole face would
come off or somethin'.
- I just wonder what,
what this is on her face
that made it so dark?
- I am so distracted by
how greasy she looks.
- I feel like this is
just really disresectful.
- I don't even think that
this sounds like her,
to be honest.
- She sounds like Columbiana in blackface.
- There's all these
quotes where it's like,
she fought for her music,
and I'm just like, she also
fought for her image.
- This is making me really sad.
(grooving music)
- The did I just watch?
- Just, no, I don't know how
to say no in so many ways,
but it just felt wrong and it was wrong.
- A lot of the crazy that
we see in the trailer,
she's like throwing
things, a lot of the anger.
- Was because she was
this darker skinned woman.
- This is just a general disappointment.
- I'm getting so emotional, I'm sorry.
- Do not get me wrong,
I think Zoe Saldana is a great actress.
- But nobody's gonna be
able to focus on how great
of an actor she is in this
movie if she's in blackface.
- I'd never think that in this day and age
that I would have to look
at something like this.
- You can get someone who's that skin tone
who is a good actress!
- But I also think that
putting all of the blame on her
is too easy.
Be mad at Zoe if you want
to, but I definitely think
that we as a collective need
to start questioning Hollywood,
we need to start questioning
places like RLJ Entertainment.
- They really should have asked someone.
They should have consulted
Nina Simone's family.
- What does it say about
my place in the world
as a Black female
if the roles that are made for me,
the stories you want to tell are about me
and I can't even play them.
- Get a panel of black Twitter
and they can tell you if it's okay or not.